former president obama is back in
hitting the campaign trail to help
democrats rake in the cash before the
midterms
it comes just a day after obama made his
heroic return to the white house to
unveil his official white house portrait
the liberal media gushing like little
school children over that
but as the nation's first and only black
president and first lady the obama said
that those portraits will tell a fuller
american story and serve as a reminder
that everyone has a place in this
country david powerful day you can see
it on the screen it was a very warm
event it was a lot of nostalgia a lot of
excitement a lot a lot of a very
celebratory atmosphere in there it was
packed in the east room i haven't seen
it that full in a really long time a
historic day former president trump did
not invite mr obama a mutual decision
according to sources still this moment
particularly poignant for the first
black president and first lady who will
live on these walls for history
look at that look at that portrait
jessica can we see that portrait again
of uh uh former president obama i find
this striking uh jessica can we see it
there because you notice what's missing
his background
we'll be right back
we'll be right back i think we can end
we should end this segment right now i
need to go to the back rate my skype
room would give him a zero yeah i mean i
know no that's not what he meant that's
that
no
that is a terrible one
i love it the delayed horror i was like
it's a white background i get it it
could have been something sad oh no it's
never that easy with greg
[Laughter]
just whatever requisite liberal
fangirling i was really
so pleased to see them back in the white
house yesterday it was
well you can laugh about it i he means a
lot
to the party um the portraits were
gorgeous and they were funny and sweet
and michelle was the one who conveyed
the heavier message in all of it about
you know the threats that we're facing
today and um
and you could have put me in the montage
there you go yeah we should have
it looks to me like they're your royalty
i like the queen i led with i i the
queen especially
king obama wouldn't you yeah you'd like
it isn't that what he already was he was
yes
maybe where he was from
we'll be right back i don't want to talk
judge judge i think he's going to speak
about isn't he also going to talk about
extreme maga republicans is that what
he's going to do do you think it's wise
to pile in on this like uh well they
think it's a winning message and look
they've got to do something because they
can't talk about what they did but i
have to tell you when i was listening to
those reporters it was a powerful day it
was the biggest celebration we've seen
in the east room it was exciting what
was so powerful they had a painting but
i get it i mean i get it i mean they're
happy to see them i'm happy to see a
president who can complete a sentence i
mean really i was happy to see him back
too yeah that's true you know jesse do
you uh do is there two camps here is
there a bromance between oh and and joe
or is it a feud
does joe remember him
that's a good question
i find it weird to talk about guys
relationships like there's no bromance
they just work together yes that's like
you and me bush
yeah
actually that's a bromance
like bush cheney
pence trump i mean definitely no
bromance but the the democrats always
like romanticized the deputy remember
gore goes jogging with clinton with the
little short shorts and it's like oh
they have lunch dates barack and biden
they make friendship bracelets come on
women always do this you ever go out for
drinks with your friend greg with your
guy friend and you'll come back and your
wife will be like so what'd you guys
talk about yeah like i don't know
we're like well well how is he
he's fine i guess well what did you guys
do we just we just watched the game and
she's like yeah isn't that cute like
what are you talking about you just
brought this back to the a block right
who was talking about royalty and who
wasn't yeah we were like sitting here
going like what do we say and you guys
were like all in it was like you could
have talked up you could have done we
could have done three hours i also did
our assignment
yes that's true you did your assignment
i guess we did so i guess we should
blame megan megan albano our producer oh
no i blame her
for sure do you think um do you think
how's do you think he helps the
democrats well i was get i was
astonished by this obama news that i i
thought that everything was turning
around for the democrats i thought
everything was great yeah i thought they
were you know they're passing all this
legislation the gas prices are ticking
down inflation's ticking down biden's
going up like why do they need obama and
arguably you could say if you're the
biden team they've had many more
legislative accomplishments than obama
did and obama had 60 senators right and
if i would believe me
in the feud those playing out behind the
scenes if you ever see their private
text messages the biden people were
picking up on that and they are lording
it over the obama people quietly oh
interesting
spicy
maybe not i don't know
all right
intrigue palace intrigue yeah i just
learned that hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else